bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous on
est ensemble pour 90 minutes de débats
de reportage et d'expertise comme tous
les soirs sur Public Sénat vous savez la
promesse est dans le titre donner du
sens à l'actualité se mettre au service
du public vous proposez des clés de
compréhension des mutations de notre
société et voici le sommaire de ce 12
janvier le ministre Pape Ndiaye qui
demande aux enseignants de CM1 et de CM2
d'organiser une dictée par jour il m'est
également en place une heure de soutien
en maths ou en français pour les élèves
de 6e et la question de l'uniforme
refait son apparition avec l'ancienne
prof devenu première dame Brigitte
Macron qui soutient cette idée face au
lecteur du Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France bref c'est le retour des
fondamentaux à l'école et puis dans
l'actualité il y a encore et toujours
l'Ukraine la guerre à un tournant selon
Joe Biden
en ce moment la guerre en Ukraine a
atteint un tournant nous devons faire
tout ce que nous pouvons pour aider les
Ukrainiens à résister à l'agression
russe
la Russie ne cherche pas à ralentir
les actions sont aussi barbares qu'il y
a un an et il ne lâche rien du tout rien
du tout
un conflit aux portes de l'Union
européenne qui rebat les cartes des
alliances est-ce un nouvel ordre mondial
qui se construit depuis près d'un an ne
ratez pas notre second débat dans trois
quarts d'heure mais d'abord est-ce une
coïncidence Brigitte Macron qui se dit
favorable au port de l'uniforme à
l'école le jour où le rassemblement
national le propose dans sa niche
parlementaire à l'Assemblée Fabien Ecker
à l'école Brigitte Macron est pour elle
affirmé dans un entretien accordé au
lecteur du Parisien ce la gomme les
différences on gagne du temps et de
l'argent par rapport aux marques donc je
suis pour le port de l'uniforme à
l'école mais avec une tenue simple et
pas tristounne l'idée c'est aussi son
chemin au Parlement mais uniquement à
droite à l'Assemblée nationale les
députés examinaient cet après-midi un
texte du RN en ce sens au Sénat c'est
une proposition de loi déposée par le
groupe les républicains qui prévoit de
rendre l'uniforme obligatoire la
problématique c'est qu'on est dans une
société de l'image ou la tyrannie des
marques fait qu'entre jeunes élèves
parfois et bien les rapports peuvent
être compliqués du fait du vêtement mais
de lave même de ce sénateur l'uniforme
ne règlerait pas tous les problèmes de
l'école et notamment celui du faible
niveau en orthographe des écoliers
français 27% d'entre eux ne savent pas
lire correctement à leur entrée en 6e
le ministre prend donc un retour au
fondamentaux et notamment un
renforcement de la dictée en CM1 et CM2
des recommandations cette semaine vont
être adressées aux professeur au
formateur et aux inspecteurs afin que
soient instaurer partout dans la foulée
d'un rapport de l'Inspection générale la
pratique régulière de la dictée la
pratique quotidienne de la rédaction une
déclaration volontariste mais qui fait
sourire les syndicats la dictée figurant
déjà dans les programmes à l'école
primaire c'est pas nouveau ça fait déjà
des années qu'on demande aux enseignants
de faire une dictée quotidienne c'était
le cas de Najat Vallaud-Belkacem c'était
le cas de Jean-Michel Blanquer c'était
même une marotte pour lui donc il y a
pas de nouveautés là-dedans et les
enseignants font cet exercice là c'est
de la communication politique les
syndicats dénoncent surtout les classes
surchargées dans certains territoires
pour expliquer les difficultés
d'apprentissage des élèves et pointe le
recours à des enseignants contractuels
insuffisamment
comment remonter le niveau des élèves
français en français et en maths faut-il
imposer une tenue scolaire à tous les
élèves en en débat avec Jean-Rémy Girard
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes professeur de
français en lycée et président du snack
Syndicat national des lycées collège et
colle est supérieur Gilbert Azoulay
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi rédacteur
en chef du Parisien étudiant directeur
général associé de l'agence
d'information Newton qui est spécialisé
dans l'éducation et là recherche et puis
je suis toujours transparent avec vous
j'accueille Laetitia cru pas bonsoir
Laetitia éditorialiste politique nous
attendons la sénatrice a l'air de Paris
Céline Boulay espéronier qui était aussi
spécialiste de ces questions d'éducation
elle arrivera d'ici quelques minutes
allez on va commencer par la dictée
notre niveau en
orthographe depuis 1987 la même dictée
et proposer tous les ans un échantillon
d'élèves de CM2 voilà ce que ça donnait
en 1987 il y avait
10,7 fautes en moyenne 20 ans plus tard
on passe à 14,4 fautes et en 2021 on est
après de 20 faut 19,4 fautes en moyenne
Jean-Émile Girard le niveau
d'orthographe il baisse personne peut
nier ce constat comment vous l'expliquez
alors personne peut nier ce constat nous
au snack ça fait quand même depuis assez
longtemps qu'on essaye de le faire
passer ce constat il y a beaucoup de
facteurs explicatifs il y a tous les
facteurs j'allais dire désaffections
pour l'éducation nationale difficulté de
recrutement manque de formation on va
évidemment en parler de plus en plus de
contractuels qui ne sont pas formés non
plus donc détails des classes qui sont
très très élevés très des classes
chargées aussi donc ça aide pas
forcément à aider les élèves de manière
plus individuelle et il y a aussi moi ce
que j'ai vécu j'ai fait 9 ans 9 ans de
collège on a eu toute une période où
enseigner la grammaire faire des
exercices répétitifs d'orthographe etc
c'était plus que déconseillé par notre
constitution c'était limite interdits
faire des heures de grammaire quand j'ai
commencé c'était pas supposé moi j'étais
dans les années 2000 là c'était les
programmes de 96 de mémoire où ça c'est
vraiment lancé cette idée là pas
quelqu'un derrière votre épaule qui
regardait ce que vous faisiez alors il y
avait quand même des inspecteurs des
formateurs qui étaient là-dessus et
effectivement c'était le règne de ce
qu'on appelle la séquence pédagogique ou
en fait on étudie un texte et pendant
l'étude du texte hop on voyait un petit
point de grammaire en passant on faisait
un petit exercice et puis on continue
c'est variable les pratiques des
collègues sont très très disparate en
fait parce qu'aujourd'hui on sait plus
trop à quel Saint se voué c'est un peu
compliqué quand votre inspecteur vient
vous dire exactement le contraire de ce
qui vous disait il y a 5 ans également
oh c'est rarement les inspecteurs les
collègues des prophètes les professeurs
des écoles dans le premier degré le voit
davantage que nous souvent dans le
second degré on les voit on les voit
assez peu donc effectivement il y a
beaucoup de pratiques qui peuvent être
assez disparate qui vont avec le fait
que le nombre d'heures de français a eu
tendance à diminuer comme le nombre
d'élèves par classe a eu tendance à
augmenter vous mettez tout ça faut pas
s'étonner que ça se passe pas très bien
à l'arrivée donc manque de moyens manque
de professeur formé ça en y reviendra et
puis moi j'appelle ça le pédagogie mais
alors c'est c'est un terme qui est assez
péjoratif mais
Gilbert Azoulay effectivement est-ce
qu'il y a eu des errants pédagogiques
quoi c'est à dire que là on a un
témoignage très direct le jour dit on a
titre 13 débat le retour aux femmes
fondamentaux on les avait laissé un peu
un peu loin derrière puis surtout je
pense que l'essentiel c'est que les
inégalités sociales se sont creusées
donc on a tiré vers le bas la moyenne
c'est mathématiques c'est à dire que les
bons élèves eux s'en sortent toujours
qu'on soit bien d'accord et ceux qui
n'arrivaient pas à suivre quel que soit
la méthode d'ailleurs là où je vous
reprends simplement les profs ont assez
grande latitude pour faire leurs cours
de grammaire ou pas d'ajouter tel ou tel
chose vous le dites vous-même en lycée
en collège les inspecteurs viennent
assez peu je crois que c'était une fois
tous les 10 ans tous les 15 ans alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe le programme on
est sanctionné ou pas j'ai jamais j'ai
rarement
les enseignants qui soient sanctionnés
dans sa carrière on va rater le passage
alors classe éventuellement ce genre de
petites choses là je veux pas de plus
défendre le corps d'inspection
évidemment et qui est pas très qui est
pas très dense plus parce qu'il pourrait
apporter vraiment une expertise aux
enseignants l'échange se fait du coup
assez brutalement parfois puisque il
arrive il dit c'est pas comme ça c'est
comme ça alors qu'il pourrait avoir une
bonne latitude pour pour les combats
les enseignants pédagogiques on enseigne
aussi de la façon dont on est formé et
dont on a appris pour faire de la
liberté pédagogique faut qu'on vous
apprenne différentes méthodes
différentes façons de faire faut que
vous puissiez choisir et fabriquer votre
pédagogue d'ailleurs durée sur les
exemples de la dictée il est très bon
faut faire une dictée tous les jours
d'accord est-ce que c'est une dictée de
mots est-ce que c'est une dictée
préparée est-ce que c'est une dictée
surprise est-ce que c'est une dictée je
sais pas préparer avec un camarade
quelle est la bonne méthode moi je ne
sais pas personnellement je suis pas
pédagogue de quoi on voit bien qu'il y a
une attitude énorme et extrêmement
variée dans les approches pédagogiques
qui peuvent être menées cet exemple
dédié il était il est vraiment clair
quand le ministre a dit ça mais je dis
quel type de quelle dictée il parle en
fait en réalité alors je ne sais pas
est-ce que est-ce que les consignes sont
claires surtout on entendait dans dans
notre reportage dans le sujet de
fabienker un de vos collègues qui disait
mais
ça fait quoi deux trois ministres qui
qui nous disent les mêmes choses c'est
ça mais alors oui c'est une c'est quoi
si on est précis qu'est-ce que vous avez
reçu et est-ce que ça s'impose dans les
programmes comment ça se passe donc
c'est le troisième ministre d'affilée
qui nous parle de la dictée quotidienne
ça avait commencé avec Najat
Vallaud-Belkacem il y en avait eu avant
hein déjà qui était sur sur ce thème là
et ça n'est pas dans les programmes ça
n'est pas dans les programmes et ça ne
sera toujours pas puisque là ce qu'on a
reçu ce sont ce qu'on appelle des notes
de service c'est-à-dire le niveau le
plus bas de de l'injonction on va dire
qui vont être très peu lu et on va pas
se le cacher non plus bah les notes de
service du ministère c'est pas très lu
hein c'est pas très lu on reçoit plein
de papiers on a plein de choses à faire
et je vous assure que aller se taper la
note de service pour essayer de trouver
peut-être un petit point intéressant au
milieu globalement
de vous réunir de vous
ministre successifs qui qui alors c'est
de la communication
politique j'entends cet argument mais
bon on peut aussi se dire que un
ministre qui arrive il se dit tiens je
vais peut-être être le premier enfin
pour de bons réintroduire une dictée
quotidienne donc pourquoi ça coince
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui bloque ça
semble ça semble assez évident comme en
plus moi je pense que politiquement dans
l'opinion on voit bien l'intérêt donc
donc pouvoir dire je suis vraiment le
ministre qui a fait en sorte que ce soit
effectif qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
parce que on a parlé déjà c'est 800000
personnes à faire bouger simultanément
c'est un paquebot c'est à dire que faire
bouger quelque chose ne serait-ce un
court un enseignement ou des des accords
d'enseignants c'est compliqué donc on
essaye de faire de colmater parfois
certaines brèches j'ai retrouvé une note
de service d'y à 5 ans sur les maths on
disait on
identifier le fait que nos élèves soient
sont très mauvais voilà résolution de
problèmes mathématique il y a 5 ans donc
aujourd'hui on dit on est mauvais en
maths on le savait il y a 5 ans mais
rien n'a été fait donc je confirme un
peu ce que vous disiez maintenant moi je
pense que est-ce qu'il y a un peu de de
une volonté parfois des organisations
syndicales pose la question aujourd'hui
c'est aussi une pour y répondre aussi
parce que plusieurs ministres moi je
suis très indulgent avec les ministres
d'éducation je sais pas vous mentir
j'avais nagé de peuple nager n'achète
Valou Belkacem avec qui je faisais un
débat aussi Luc Ferry il disait mais au
fond je discute alors j'ai demandé
à notre ami nous confirmé on discute
ensemble dans le bureau on est plutôt
d'accord sur le diagnostic ils sortent
sur le perron et ils disent c'est le
contraire exactement le contraire sur le
thème non mais c'est pas possible on
n'est pas d'accord avec cela alors je
posais des questions c'est pas vrai sur
cette réforme on n'a pas été du tout
consulté sauf des offres des petits
bruits des petits rumeurs et comme
ceux-là mais moi je pense que le les
gouvernements successifs ont peur de
faire bouger des choses qui
idéologiquement pourraient remuer un
certain terreau de contestation touché
au programme c'est toucher le Graal même
si on appelait plus grands inspecteurs
même si on appelle le CNR même si on
appelle tous les tous les spécialistes
c'est très compliqué c'est pour ça qu'on
essaye d'influencer avec des notes de
service qui là à la vérité ne changeront
rien du tout excepté excepté dans les
lycées d'excellence que les
établissements d'excellence on peut
donner les moyens avec des enseignants
qui peut suivre le programme ça pardon
c'est pas quelque chose qui peut être on
va y revenir Laetitia j'accueille Céline
boulet peronnier bonsoir bienvenue
parce que vous avez dit plutôt 25 donc
il est 13 c'est super on va gagner 10
minutes 12 minutes dans le dans le
timing non c'est très bien vous êtes
sénatrice a l'air de de Paris alors là
on a on a chapitre ce débat on commence
par la dictée on parlera des maths après
on va faire un peu le bilan du du
ministre on terminera par l'uniforme
donc là on est sur le la dictée le
niveau en en français et on est sur le
fait que finalement plusieurs ministres
se sont succédé en disant il faut faire
une dictée quotidienne et que elle a
jamais vraiment été intégrée au
programme et jamais vraiment été intégré
question à une sénatrice LR sur
les ministres de droite parce que c'est
une bonne mini c'est une bonne mesure
pour un ministre de droite non de dire
j'ai réintroduit la dictée quotidienne
pourquoi ça n'a pourquoi on n'y arrive
pas alors ce qui m'amuse c'est que on
arrête pas de dire que cléverses
gauche-droite c'est terminé et puis la
dictée de droite ça côté de gauche c'est
drôle parce que finalement on en revient
toujours à ses fondamentaux finalement
qui qui rejoignent des clivages
politiques d'une certaine manière pour
quand on y arrive pas pourquoi par
rapport à la dictée oui pourquoi en fait
c'est une espèce de serpent de merde et
que qui est toujours pas dans les
programmes et qui est toujours pas très
posé l'éducation sur ce plateau que je
ne suis pas moi moi je suis très
favorable la dictée parce que je suis
favorable au fondamentaux d'accord on
est dans une société d'ailleurs qui
par les crises qu'elle traverse c'est le
fait qu'elle est relativement fracturée
a besoin paradoxalement de revenir assez
fondamentaux me semble-t-il aujourd'hui
une partie de la population nous demande
ça la dictée pour moi c'est un exercice
de bon sens et quand on voit à quel
point le niveau d'orthographe a baissé
dans l'école de la République et même
chez les adultes aujourd'hui on se dit
que finalement bien c'est un
entraînement qui est nécessaire mais
c'est drôle parce que quand on parlait
de la dictée il y a 14 ou 15 ans on se
moquait de nous on était espèce
d'audience et puis finalement on y
revient donc les fondamentaux et bien
porte bien leur nom à un moment quand ça
va pas on y revient et on fait des
expérimentations peut-être quand la
situation est moins grave
que on fait quasiment deux fois plus de
fautes aujourd'hui enfin les élèves de
CM2 par rapport à 1987
toutes les semaines ou tous les jours je
sais pas ça réglera pas le problème de
niveau qu'on soit bien d'accord c'est
l'apprentissage des savoirs excessément
c'est s'intéresser au thermomètre alors
que les le mal est bien plus profond me
semble-t-il en fait la dictée c'est un
exercice de réflexion c'est un exercice
de contrôle aussi effectivement mais
c'est l'évaluation ça ça participe mais
si on enseigne pas l'orthographe
explicitement à côté on peut toujours
faire toutes les dictées du monde elles
seront toujours mauvaises si on n'a pas
enseigné l'orthographe la grammaire de
façon régulière de façon
je vous le dis ça a eu très mauvaise
presse la grammaire dans le système
éducatif la grammaire a été près du
doigt comme étant une pratique
rétrograde comme étant une pratique qui
ne faisait pas sens on a eu tout ça et
je on s'en est mais bouffer hein de de
la grammaire sur laquelle on a tapé
dessus comme ça alors vous n'avez pas
répondu à ce que l'anecdote que que
sur on va dire quoi la posture
finalement des organisations syndicales
vous nous donniez un retour de plusieurs
ministres qui disait quand ils sont dans
mon bureau on est d'accord sur les
solutions quand ils sortent sur le
perron c'est non on n'en veut pas alors
nous au snack on est réputé pour être
très transparent c'est-à-dire qu'on
tient le même discours au ministre et au
personnel et c'est connu ça au niveau du
ministère de l'Éducation nationale mais
sur la dictée pour vous puisqu'on est ce
sujet là pour vous montrer effectivement
lorsque c'était Najat velo Belkacem qui
a fait changer les programmes en 2015
elle avait annoncé la dictée quotidienne
et le calcul mental quotidien et dans
les projets de programme on retrouvait
le calcul mental quotidien c'était écrit
noir sur blanc et on ne retrouvait pas
la dictée quotidienne et bah qui a fait
le snalk on a proposé un amendement au
Conseil supérieur de l'éducation pour
écrire la dictée quotidienne voilà et ça
a été refusé par le le mystère alors que
la ministre disait qu'elle faisait la
dictée quotidienne donc voilà une fois
encore nous on a un moment la ministre
disait quelque chose on disait qu'on
l'écrive et on a refusé de l'écrire à ce
moment-là c'est une boulette est-ce
qu'on écoute les parents aussi parce que
les parents eux-mêmes ont eu à faire ce
genre d'exercice du calcul mental la
dictée etc est-ce que eux
je m'adresse à vous en vous demandant ça
est-ce que eux vous suggèrent disputiez
revenez à ces fondamentaux là est-ce que
il suivent ça certains j'avais presque
dire une certaine catégorie de parents
oui parce qu'il y a aussi des parents
qui sont complètement dépassés par le
système éducatif qui n'y comprennent
rien des des parents célibataires
souvent des femmes qui n'ont pas
forcément le temps de s'occuper de tout
ce qu'elle voudrait mais oui il y a cet
aspect là beaucoup de parents sont très
très sensibles à des choses telles que
le bled le Bescherelle tous ces sortes
de jalons comme ça nous rappelle ce
qu'on a parce que les grands-parents
soutien scolaires ensuite le point
important c'est que le bled le
Bescherelle etc ça une vertu très forte
c'est que ça faisait faire des exercices
réguliers c'est vraiment ça qu'on a
perdu cette régularité de l'entrée alors
j'ai une question pardon on parle tous
en même temps pardon Laetitia je
reprends la main c'est une question qui
est née de discussion au sein de la
rédaction de Public Sénat cet après-midi
je ne vous cache pas que mes enfants
sont très très grands ils ont passé
l'âge scolaire depuis un bon moment mais
en revanche il y a plusieurs de des
journalistes de la rédaction qui ont des
enfants jeunes et l'une d'entre elles je
ne vais pas la citer me disait mais
c'est dingue il y a plus de notes et la
dictée ça peut en général finir par une
note est-ce que c'est pas l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles on certains je
dis pas je ne fais pas de La Malga mais
hésite à faire à faire des dictées en
classe non c'est pas la question du
système d'évaluation même si nous on
trouve au snack que la note c'est un
système d'évaluation tout à fait
sympathique et que parfois avec les
compétences on fait des choses un petit
peu bizarres et puis ensuite nos élèves
additionnent les points verts et les
points rouges et font des notes avec
avec les points donc
finalement
on se triture beaucoup le cerveau pour
retourner à la même chose la même chose
aux États-Unis
il y a une question de temps
c'est-à-dire qu'on demande de plus en
plus de choses aux collègues notamment
au professeurs des écoles dans des temps
qui sont de plus en plus contraints et
dans des conditions qui sont plus en
plus compliquées donc à un moment les
professeurs des écoles et les
professeurs de 6e se retrouvent de toute
façon ils ne vont pas pouvoir bien faire
leur travail et faire tout ce qu'on leur
demande de faire donc ils font des choix
donc ils font peut-être moins de dictées
ou moins d'exercices pour faire plus de
rédaction ou à l'inverse ce qui insiste
peut-être plus sur la grammaire et bien
ils font peut-être moins écrire les
élèves ils font moins d'expressions
écrites alors pour évaluer le niveau des
élèves français il y a ce fameux
classement pizza la France la France 23e
sur 79 pays lors du dernier classement
on est à peu près on est dans les eaux
on va dire de l'Allemagne la Belgique et
le Portugal loin derrière les pays les
plus performants Canada Finlande ou
Royaume-Uni et puis alors si on zoome un
peu sur les mathématiques parce qu'on va
parler des mathématiques maintenant les
résultats donc c'est une évaluation de
2018 on est un peu au dessus de la
moyenne de l'OCDE entre la 15e et la 24e
place c'est sur les matières
scientifiques et puis ce qui est
intéressant c'est que nos résultats
moyen en mathématiques ont baissé entre
2003 et 2018 on parle des maths parce
que l'autre annonce du ministre ça
concerne les classes de 6e la mise en
place d'une heure de soutien par semaine
en français ou en maths effectivement
c'est une boule à espéronier est-ce que
là on parle de la sixième est-ce que
c'est pas déjà un peu trop tard c'est
est-ce que pour remonter le niveau des
élèves en maths on était sur la dictée
la question pour revalor aussi est-ce
que c'est pas plutôt quoi dès le
primaire il faut y aller
dans ma scolarité j'avais bien d'autres
qualités mais je peux vous dire que moi
les maths ça a commencé manulité bien
avant le sixième malheureusement et
après j'ai ramené pour parler
vulgairement pour remonter le niveau au
moins c'était bien avant ça et j'avais
des petits camarades pour lesquels
c'était le cas donc là quand on parle de
fondamentaux il me semble que c'est les
fondamentaux des fondamentaux c'est de
commencer bien avant je pense que pour
la sixième encore une fois je parle sous
le contrôle de nos amis ici mais il me
semble que c'est bien avant et
d'ailleurs le niveau en mathématiques ne
cesse de baisser mais c'est pas nouveau
depuis je sais pas des années non depuis
les indicateurs en 2015 indiqués
clairement qu'on était en dessous du
niveau oui mais alors c'est intéressant
parce qu'on n'est pas que nul en maths
si on va vers l'élite on s'est formé des
très très doué en maths aussi c'est ce
que j'ai remarqué d'abord et là
aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que les maths ça illustre
tout c'est au début que ça joue la
primaire le clivage il est fait entre
ceux qui réussiront ceux qui réussissent
pas ceux qui réussiront pas moi ce que
je constate je traite beaucoup des
problématiques de grandes écoles ou
d'excellence en matière de recherche la
France se place plutôt bien on recherche
nos ingénieurs les entreprises
internationales recrutent nos ingénieurs
recrutent nos diplômés des grandes
écoles 30% des étudiants de grande école
de commerce travailler à l'étranger
quand même dans les entreprises
françaises ou dans les entreprises
multinationales la recherche on est pas
mal sur les mathématiques sur la
physique avec Jussieu avec Orsay sur
l'électronique donc on arrive à ça veut
dire qu'on s'est généré de l’excellence
interromptes médailles field on va dire
il était pas bon ministre puisqu'il est
pas resté longtemps mais en tout cas
c'était un très bon mathématicien mais
et je me demande toujours on est à peu
près un peu moins 3 millions étudiants
en France j'ai généré de l'excellence
parmi ces élites parmi les diplômes on
manque de docteur pourquoi on génère pas
plus de docteur c'est quand même dommage
on manque d'ingénieur en manque de
diminuer chaque année pourquoi on en a
pas plus alors qu'on sait les former la
formation des écoles d'ingénieurs
françaises elle sert de modèle que ce
soit dans les pays émergents comme en
Afrique mais également dans les autres
pays qui sont en Asie ou ailleurs donc
on nous des partenariats avec les
Chinois qui copient nos modèles donc on
sait faire de l'excellence académique et
je trouve ça dommage que on alors on se
focalise sur le primaire puisque tout se
joue mais on sait les amener vers
l'excellence pour les meilleurs d'entre
eux et un grand nombre d'ailleurs alors
votre réaction à cette alors là pour le
coup c'est pas une note c'est c'est ce
sera dans les programmes le secteur de
soutien en 6e en français ou tomates
sauf que j'ai lu juste avant que
l'émission démarre que ça se faisait au
détriment du nord de technologie donc on
déshabille Paul pour habiller Jacques
c'est ça c'est exactement
ça absolument scandaleux c'est
absolument scandaleux on est en train de
mettre en place l'heure de soutien la
plus complexe la plus usine à gaz qu'on
a pu imaginer où il faudra que des
professeurs des écoles arrive dans le
collège à un moment où ils ont pas cours
dans des classes qui sont plus des
classes parce qu'il faudrait regrouper
les élèves par compétence et non plus
par groupe classe donc il faut aligner
toutes les classes les chefs
d'établissement vont être avis sur les
emplois du temps voilà en groupe à
effectif réduit nous dit le ministre
mais a priori sans les moyens pour faire
des groupes à effectifs réduits donc par
paquet de 28 voilà en choisissant ou le
français ou les maths on peut même pas
faire les deux alors même que nos élèves
généralement ils ont des difficultés ou
de toute façon il y a besoin de soutien
dans les deux et en plus on supprime la
technologie alors même que le ministre a
dit il y a une semaine qu'il fallait
revaloriser la technologie la
technologie s'était formidable que
c'était ultra important que ça aidait
etc et que ça a des liens assez forts
avec des poursuites d'études en voie
professionnelle ou en voie technologique
et que c'est quelque chose de très
intéressant même si les programmes
actuels sont pas géniaux en techn on est
demandeur qu'on les qu'on les revoit
mais oui la discipline technologique
c'est une discipline très très
utile et ça c'est hallucinant alors vous
savez pourquoi ils font ça parce qu'on a
du mal à avoir des professeurs de
technologie donc on a beaucoup d'heures
de cours en technologie qui sont perdus
donc on fait passer pour une mesure
pédagogique une mesure de gestion des
ressources humaines et de gestion de la
pénurie ma vie privée mais ça existe
déjà dans le collège par exemple de ma
fille ses heures de soutenir existent
déjà donc c'est possible donc peut-être
que je vous mets en relation avec un
cours francilien pour vous montrer que
ce système fonctionne parfaitement
c'est à l'heure de de du déjeuner et les
élèves qui sont en difficulté le demande
et ont des heures de soutien allez je il
est 18h24 il nous reste 20 minutes dans
ce débat j'aurais qu'on parle de un peu
de Papé Ndiaye quand même du du ministre
et ça communication
Laetitia vous dites qu'elle est
finalement menée pour ne pas froisser le
corps enseignant qui s'est dit malmener
pendant les années Blanquer ah oui on
peut dire que la méthode pas pendji
c'est l'anti Ibiza pourquoi je parle
diviser ça parce que rappelez-vous
c'était il y a un an tout juste c'est
interview donnée par Jean-Michel
Blanquer dans les colonnes du Parisien
lu par les enseignants qui découvrait
via la presse finalement les conditions
dans laquelle la rentrée 2023 allait se
faire les conditions avec encore un
covid qui était fort et on apprenait par
la suite que Jean-Michel Blanquer ne la
mette pas donner depuis son bureau
c'était interview mais depuis bissa où
il passait sa lune de miel bon ça a
marqué au fer rouge le corps enseignant
et là on est bon on est carrément aux
antipodes
de communication complètement c'est pas
Penda et finalement il fait des notes
alors peut-être que vous ne l'avez pas
lu je ne sais pas parce que vous avez
trop de papier à lire en tout cas il
envoie ses notes encore enseignant
ensuite il vient dans les médias ce
matin il était sûr RMC pour expliquer
ces heures de soutien pour expliquer
cette dictée obligatoire pour expliquer
les mesures qu'il normalement il avait
déjà annoncé au préalable aux
enseignants on n'écoute pas Ndiaye
je crois que nous n'avons pas
moi j'aime bien ça communication
est-ce que vous diriez que c'est quand
même une communication à l'endroit oui
pourquoi parce que normalement si tout
se passe bien les enseignants sont tenus
au courant puis le ministre se déplace
dans les médias pour quand même informer
le grand public les premiers concernés
sont les Français sont les familles les
parents et puis les enfants donc cela
pourrait changer finalement le rapport
du ministre et avec sa base d'ailleurs
vous avez remarqué aussi Thomas qui est
très discret dans les médias on le dit
notre jargon c'est pas joli ces
expressions mais ce n'est pas un
de micro il reste c'est pas la plus
belle expression on est d'accord
secret et je pense que Emmanuel Macron
le savait le nom ou du moins il savait
un peu il imaginait que ce serait cette
méthode là cette méthode là que pour
laquelle opterait papa appendi et après
est-ce que cette confiance qui est en
passe d'être restaurée aura un impact
sur les futurs manifestations
anti-retraite parce que du côté de
l'exécutif on est en train aussi de se
poser la question elle lui a écouté s'il
fallait donner une réponse ce soir à
faire à Paris je voudrais dire que non
que pour l'instant Pape Ndiaye tente
d'instaurer la paix dans son périmètre à
l'éducation nationale mais de là à
finalement convaincre les enseignants
qui eux veulent aller manifester de ne
pas se se rendre dans la rue ça c'est
quand même très difficile à dire parce
que l'antimachronisme existe
profondément dans cette institution qui
est l'éducation nationale Céline voulait
espéronier j'ai repris les adjectifs qui
avaient été donné par plusieurs
Parlement
leader LR quand papélia a été nommé au
ministère de l'Éducation nationale
walkiste islamo-gauchiste promoteur du
sectarisme est-ce que c'était pas quand
même un peu injuste
c'est difficile à dire en tout cas
virage 180 à 180 par rapport à Blanquer
et la méthode blanquette c'est vraiment
l'opposé qui a été nommé et là aussi ça
donne quelle image et je me mets à la
place de la communauté éducative qui se
dit finalement on passe d'une stratégie
à une stratégie totalement différente
interrogée par mes collègues lors de la
première audition de papel Ndiaye en
commission des collègues qui voulaient
savoir vraiment de quoi ce ministre
était fait parce qu'il le découvrait ils
étaient assez inquiets en se disant
c'est quand même curieux bon
il avait assez mal réagi en disant vous
avez mal lu mais mais donc on a
l'impression quand même d'un espèce de
positionnement relativement curieux de
la part de ce ministre depuis le début
qu'on a du mal à cerner qui d'ailleurs a
du mal à trouver sa place au sein du
gouvernement c'est quand même le
ministre c'est quand même le ministre de
l'Éducation et parce que il fait des
réponses qui sont un petit peu en
mi-temps ils ne nous dit pas exactement
entre guillemets ce qui est là dans le
ventre et on a du mal à savoir
exactement comment il se positionne il y
a vraiment on a le sentiment qu'il est
là effectivement pour temporiser par
rapport à la communauté éducative et il
existe pas vraiment et d'ailleurs je
vais prendre des mesures
particulièrement pro je sais pas
islamo-gauchiste pardon mais par rapport
à autre chose mais il a son expliqué
justement action bon est-ce que ça
disait une confiance en passe d’être
restauré oui non est-ce que vous le
voyez comment ça se passe avec ce
ministre ah non pas du tout hein vous
voyez alors la confiance n'est pas en
face d'être restée d'accord la dernière
fois qu'on a une audience avec lui
c'était à la rentrée de septembre donc
ça c'était quand même bien un petit
moment
j'ai pas confiance a priori on a
l'impression que vous êtes en fait c'est
la même politique qui continue d'être
menée nous honnêtement en tant que
représentant syndicale moi je m'en fiche
de qui est ministre moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est quels sont les mesures
qui sont prises est-ce que ça va dans le
bon sens dans le mauvais sens là
supprimer supprimer la technologie en 6e
pour nous très clairement ça va dans le
mauvais sens et que ce soit ce serait
pas peine dire que ce serait Jean-Michel
Blanquer ce serait n'importe qui ce
serait la même chose
donc là nous on a quand même assez bien
compris qu'il avait été nommé là
probablement pour un côté assez
symbolique pour essayer effectivement de
d'incarner autre chose que Jean-Michel
Blanquer qui avait très fortement épuisé
le corps enseignant et l'éducation
nationale mais si on juge les fesses la
politique vous dites c'est à peu près la
même politique alors il y a eu toute une
période où il y a pas eu grand chose le
temps d'accord c'est Marc sans aucun
doute voilà mais enfin c'est très
brouillon c'est pas très clair ça je
vous rejoins c'est pas très clair il a
la semaine dernière quand il était
interviewé il a dit des choses et
ensuite le ministère est obligé de dire
alors non c'est pas tout à fait ça c'est
pas tous les enseignants qui va être
valorisés comme il a dit ce seront que
les 20-25 premières années de carrière
il a il avait annoncé son heure de
soutien français mathématique il avait
quand même oublié de dire qu'on
supprimait une heure de technologie en
échange voilà donc c'est quelque chose
qui est pas toujours très nette c'est
quand même pas un grand connaisseur de
l'éducation nationale au départ donc
forcément il prend du temps aussi
technicien pour vous c'est pas qu'il est
assez technicien ou pas assez technicien
en soi c'est qu'effectivement là on n'a
pas l'impression que il porte vraiment
les choses et quand on a jamais
mais madame l'éducation nationale est en
crise 3500 postes n'ont pas été pourvu
au concours d'andernier
mais revaloriser les enseignants les
pays mieux alors ça existe effectivement
chargé correctement voilà ça déjà c'est
trois trucs là on fait ça je vous assure
que ça ira mieux dans l'éducation je
vais vous donner la parole mais
justement puisqu'on parle de de
finalement des conditions et peut-être
aussi du recrutement des enseignants
pour améliorer le niveau en maths en
français encore faut-il avoir des des
professeurs regardez cette plateforme où
il y a pas cours qui est proposé par la
Fédération des parents d'élèves FCPE
elle comptabilise le nombre d'heures de
cours perdues à cause d'enseignants
absents non remplacé alors là c'était en
fin de matinée peut-être début
d'après-midi qu'on a fait cette
captation d'écran voilà vous le voyez on
est à près de 22000 heures de cours
depuis la rentrée et c'est ce que
craignait la sénatrice socialiste Martin
filleul elle réclame un choc
d'attractivité écoutez
face à cette crise du recrutement des
enseignants et aux sentiments de
déclassement qu'il accompagne il faut un
électrochoc
d'attractivité et une vraie augmentation
des salaires les rémunérations ne sont
pas à la hauteur la France et l'un des
pays qui paye le moins bien ses
enseignants songer un peu le 21e rang de
l'OCDE recourir aux contractuels aux
étudiants comme vous le proposez ne fait
que repousser le problème c'est une
réponse conjoncturelle et non une
réponse structurelle plus on attend plus
les dégâts seront importants
ce manque de professeur est-ce que c'est
d'abord une question salariale ou est-ce
que c'est plus compliqué que ça je pense
que c'est plus compliqué que ça
évidemment la question salariale et les
fondamentale et le cœur de tout
d'ailleurs la première fois qu'on a
auditionné le ministre il avait dit à la
rentrée il y aura un enseignant devant
chaque classe ça ça favoriser aussi la
confiance qu'on a eu en lui parce qu'on
s'est aperçu qu'après il
il tamisait ses propos enfin il les
atténuaient et qu'il s'était aperçu et
là je rejoins ce que vous disiez
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas un technicien
que finalement il est arrivé pas donc il
y a ça et après c'est vraiment à vous de
me l'expliquer mais je pense qu'il y a
un manque d'attractivité pour le métier
peut-être parce qu'il y a différents
problèmes qui conversent et que
finalement le métier d'enseignant est
peut-être de plus en plus difficile on
parlait des sapeurs fondamentaux il y a
peut-être aussi beaucoup
d'administratifs il y a peut-être une
certaine peur aussi par rapport à une
défiance de l'autorité vis-à-vis des
lèvres qui sont peut-être de plus en
plus difficiles peut-être une certaine
violence aussi au sein de l'école et
puis un métier qui n'est pas assez
valorisé là je vous rejoins totalement
Gilbert Azoulay je viens vers vous et
votre expertise et est-ce que cette
crise d'évocation on l'a on la voyait
montée depuis plusieurs années bah oui
bien sûr il y a eu beaucoup de
modifications dans la formation
elle-même les cursus de formation
étaient contestés donc ils ont été
discutés donc déjà ça posait un sujet en
matière de formation est-ce que faut
faire un master est-ce que attention les
aspects il y a eu les ufm il y a eu tout
une série de de filiales qui
conduisaient au métier de prof et puis
vous avez la quête de sens des nouvelles
générations des grandes écoles et
universités elle touche aussi les profs
pourquoi je m'engage dans ça on parlait
du ministère de la République je vous
rappelle il y a 50 ans aujourd'hui
est-ce que cette notion même de service
public
ussar de la République elle transpire
elle va pas tant que ça moi juste je
voulais apporter une précision et là on
voit bien ce percuter les problèmes qui
surgissent c'est que le le budget de
l'Éducation nationale il a donc natation
6,1 6,5 % en 2023 c'est pas assez c'est
beaucoup et c'est pas assez parce que il
y a un tel besoin de d'allouer des
ressources au secteur qui en ont besoin
d'allouer des ressources pour les
carrières de recruter massivement qu'on
voit bien que l'effort est écolossal en
fait amené et c'est là la vraie
difficulté aujourd'hui et c'est pareil
dans le supérieur pour la recherche il
faudrait investir massivement et en cela
le plan d'avenir les 50 milliards pour
la recherche France 2030 sont très bien
mais donc on voit bien que les
problématiques à adresser sont-elles est
tellement massives que évidemment on
essaie de les de les gérer au cas par
cas ou par coup et juste une précision
par rapport aux spécialistes Papen di
n'est pas un spécialiste mais Blanquer
était directeur général de
l'enseignement scolaire il avait été
acteur darkos avait été recteur j'ai pas
souvenir que ça a été des des ministres
fabuleux alors Jacquel ils ont pas été
forcément bien accueillis
en plus ouais combien il manque de
d'enseignants là aujourd'hui alors c'est
très compliqué parce que ça bouge ça
bouge tous les jours nous ce que l'on
sait c'est les postes qui manquent au
concours c'est à dire les les titulaires
qu'on n'arrive pas à recruter et ensuite
la technique parce qu'il y en a pas deux
il y en a qu'une c'est d'essayer de
trouver des contractuels des personnels
qui n'ont pas le concours qui ont un
niveau d'études Bac +3 globalement
parfois plus haut mais souvent bac + 3
et bah cela ils tiennent le temps qu'il
tienne donc certains
apprécient le métier par exemple
c'est c'est on vous appelle le vendredi
vous commencez le lundi là ils ont fait
parce que là il y a eu quand même
beaucoup de ramdam suite au manque de
poste dans au concours de l'an dernier
ils ont fait une incroyable formation
des cont actuelle c'est quasiment la
première fois qu'on avait ça c'était
quatre jours voilà quatre jours hop et
vous êtes professeur des écoles et vous
allez enseigner le français les maths
l'anglais l'éducation physique et
sportive les arts plastiques la musique
j'en ai oublié les sciences etc et la
technique assez importante j'ai trouvé
plutôt le speed dating puisque c'était
l'objet à la rentrée dernière aspect
dating pour recruter des profs c'est un
peu spécial mais reconnaissons au moins
cette capacité d'être agile et trouver
une solution rapide pour essayer de
résoudre un problème il faut trouver des
gens d'autres solutions de toute façon
c'est à dire soit c'est un contractuel
soit ces personnes donc à un moment oui
ils essayent de faire de la retape de la
même façon
il est moins bien payé mais voilà on a
vraiment ce problème là il est très très
sérieux et il va s'aggraver là le
ministre a donné les chiffres cette
année des inscriptions au concours c'est
pas bon dans le premier degré par
rapport alors par rapport à 2021 parce
que 2022
candidats en moins pour les professeurs
des écoles c'est un mot là-dessus on
parle des uniformes
[Musique]
épouvantable pour pour les les écoles
moi je vois des directeurs d'école à
Paris qui me disent que ils reçoivent
les enseignants qui sont formés en 4
jours ils les mettent devant une classe
il se dépatouille qui me peuvent pendant
un mois la directrice vole à leur
secours et puis finalement il s'en vont
il faut les remplacer enfin il me semble
que c'est un cassette d'ailleurs
relativement inédit mais qui est qui est
premier degré c'est assez dans le second
degré ça fait assez longtemps que ça
existe
pour pour parler comme promis du port de
l'uniforme bonsoir Tam bonsoir Thomas
bonjour à tous salut dans une émission
rock n' roll vous avez votre place on va
revenir le débat sur le port de
l'uniforme à l'école et que plusieurs
parlementaires qui veulent le rendre
obligatoire et pour commencer un rappel
le port de l'uniforme à l'école il n'a
jamais été obligatoire dans les écoles
publiques en France il y a eu le port de
la blouse mais c'était sur les vêtements
des enfants et c'était pour éviter de se
salir et aujourd'hui il y a bien
certains établissements publics pour
instaurer par exemple en outre-mer mais
c'est parce qu'ils l'ont choisi parce
qu'ils ont fait une modification du
règlement intérieur c'est donc bien
différent de ce que propose certains
parlementaires notamment vous Céline
Boulle espéronier qui voulait rendre par
la loi le port d'une tenue
d'établissement obligatoire vous ne
dites pas uniforme qui fait un petit peu
plus rigide voilà l'objectif c'est de
renforcer le sentiment d'appartenance à
l'établissement c'est de mettre en place
un facteur supplémentaire de discipline
c'est aussi de minimiser le risque de
raquette et de lutter contre les
atteintes à la laïcité effectivement
c'est ce qu'on lit dans l'exposé des
motifs de votre proposition de loi il
s'agit d'évacuer définitivement la
question du port de signe
ostensible d'appartenance religieuse aux
communautaires assurant une pleine
application du principe de laïcité cela
alors que les signalements pour
atteindre à la laïcité dans les collèges
et les lycées sont en hausse et une loi
existe importance et celle de 2004 qui a
interdit je la cite le port de signe ou
de tenue pour lesquelles les élèves
manifestent ostensiblement une app
religieuse une loi qui ne permet pas
tout qui ne permet pas par exemple
d'interdire le port d'abaya dans les
établissements scolaires ça pose
beaucoup de questions une à Bahia est-ce
que c'est une tenue traditionnelle
culturelle ou religieuse est-ce que
c'est de la provocation de la
revendication c'est là tout le sujet
pour le ministre de l'éducation
nationale pas pependji écoutez lors de
la séance de questions au gouvernement à
laquelle il avait répondu à ce sujet
c'est au mois de novembre dernier d'un
point de vue juridique la Bayane est pas
simple à définir nous serions contournés
la semaine suivante par une longueur de
robe par une forme de colle par tel ou
tel accessoire qui prolongerait de
semaine en semaine et multiplierait les
circulaires et nous emmènerait
directement au tribunal administratif et
nous perdrions tribunal administratif
voilà régler du point de vue du droit le
problème du port de vêtements religieux
à l'école ce n'est donc pas si simple et
ça ne va pas non plus être réglé par
l'uniforme c'est la vie de ce chef d'un
établissement privé à Paris lui pourtant
améliorer l'uniforme dans son école mais
après dix années où il a installé cette
idée auprès des familles écouter son
témoignage recueilli par Audrey wettaz
il ne faut pas croire que c'est
l'uniforme qui répondra aux difficultés
que pose le vêtement dit religieux c'est
un
problème beaucoup plus large la tenue à
l'école dépasse le critère religieux et
d'ailleurs si on le traite comme ça on
va braquer les jeunes on va les braquer
et on va plus encore les stigmatiser la
preuve qu'on peut avoir instauré
l'uniforme sans penser que c'est la
réforme la réponse à tout Oui et
politiquement ce débat Tam il divise
jusque dans la majorité présidentielle
oui ce matin dans le Parisien c'est
Brigitte Macron qui a été interrogé par
les lecteurs du Parisien qui se
promenons pour le port de l'uniforme
voilà elle le dit je suis pour le port
de l'uniforme à l'école c'est une
position qui a elle était opposée à
celle de papenzaï le ministre qui refuse
lui fermement de lég
au début du printemps pourquoi pourquoi
ça peut être une solution pour vous
pourquoi vous y êtes favorable alors
pour plein de raisons d'abord j'ai
entendu c'est le directeur d'école
j'entends son point de vue mais j'avais
envie de dire surtout ne faisons rien il
est urgent d'attendre quand on a autant
de problèmes qui s'accumulent bon voilà
alors sur les atteintes à la laïcité
pour en dire un mot alors que ce n'est
pas l'objet vous aurez remarqué
principal de la PPL parce qu'il y a bien
d'autres choses qui ont été développées
dans l'exposé des motifs
la vraie raison c'est pas la teinte à
laïcité non non je suis pas hypocrite du
tout je vous le dis droit dans les yeux
c'est quand même ce que ce dont vous
parlez en premier parce que si justement
alors là pour le coup je rejoins ce que
disait ce monsieur si la PPL l'objet
principal c'était les atteintes à la
laïcité là ça pourrait braquer les
élèves parce que les élèves se diraient
pourquoi puisque dans certains
territoires il y a des difficultés
devrait-on nous entre guillemets payés
en portant l'uniforme pour l'ensemble du
territoire national donc ça créerait une
inégalité qui serait contraire à l'objet
de la PPL donc
on considère que c'est le bénéfique pour
plein d'autres choses le sentiment
d'appartenance effectivement les
questions de sécurité la lutte contre le
harcèlement en réduisant les les
occasions de moqueries et ce genre de
choses mais on part de la loi de 2004
qui est une bonne loi pour la laïcité
mais autour de laquelle il y a quand
même un flou vous prenez la question des
abayas c'est un vêtement culturel c'est
un vêtement religieux tout ça n'est pas
clair le ministre nous sort donc une
circulaire le 9 novembre 2022 qui
rajoute encore un peu plus de confusion
parce qu'il dit c'est au chef
d'établissement de décider la longueur
le truc et il en rajoute une louche en
disant sur une chaîne concurrente de la
vôtre c'est quand même pas moi qui vais
regarder le matin etc donc assez
condescendant et vous vous avez
l'impression qu'il y a pas de hiérarchie
au dessus de vous pour décider de ce
genre de choses donc les parlementaires
à contrario prennent leur responsabilité
et disent on est dans on est pragmatique
on est au contact des territoires et
tout on va faire cette PPL qui aura
l'avantage d'être clair qui est un outil
qui n'est pas une la potion magique
parce qu'il a dit oui il faut pas croire
que ça va régler tous les problèmes de
l'école certainement pas mais prenons
les uns après les autres et donnant cet
outil à la communauté éducative une
dernière chose on l'a vu tout au long de
l'émission beaucoup de choses passent
sur les épaules de la communauté
éducative parce qu'on a besoin de
rajouter cette ce sujet du vêtement qui
est au cœur des débats depuis plusieurs
semaines règle le avec cette histoire de
port de Nice en tout cas un sujet que
vous avez en commun avec le
rassemblement national puisque dans la
niche parlementaire d'aujourd'hui c'est
le sujet que leur rassemblement national
a choisi l'une des propositions
cette coïncidence avec l'interview de
l'épouse d'Emmanuel Macron la première
dame qui finalement va dans le sens du
rassemblement national et qui est pas
je revendique d'accord je revendique
quand même la maternité c'est un sujet
qui n'est pas nouveau chez nous ça fait
des années qu'on en parle c'était dans
le programme de François Fillon et tout
et bien que le
pas du tout parce que d'abord notre
notre prépa est en préparation bien
avant eux le texte est plus abouti par
exemple on a introduit une mesure sur le
financement ce qui n'est pas leur cas on
voit bien eux la tentation de la fichage
ils viennent d'arriver à l'Assemblée
nationale il se dit c'est un sujet qui
est chez l'air donc nous on va poser
notre texte mais je suis désolé nous ça
fait longtemps le débat est censé
terminé moi comme c'est un tout petit
tour de table là-dessus vous êtes
favorable ou pas tiens bon on avait déjà
fait un débat sur le 45 minutes sur le
port de l'uniforme
des personnel et pas juste à titre
individuel représentant des personnels
les personnels s'en fichent de
l'uniforme mais un point que vous
n'imaginez même au moins ils sont pas
contre mais justement je vois pas très
bien pourquoi on s'embêtera avec une loi
pour le coup là le ministre il décrit
assez bien l'état du droit il y a des
établissements notamment en Martinique
où il y a alors généralement c'est le
polo et de telle couleur c'est ça c'est
pas l'uniforme tel que on peut
l'imaginer dans des collèges privés
anglais ou dans mais c'est faisable si
des communautés éducatives veulent le
faire et ben elles le font visiblement
ils ont pas très très envie de le faire
l'imposer dans tous les établissements
c'est là que ça se complique c'est ça
faut que il y a des expérimentations ou
que ou cela est possible ce que je
regrette simplement c'est quand j'ai eu
l'interview de Macron j'aurais aimé
qu'elle dise je l'ai porté à 15 ans ça
m'a pas posé de problème il faudrait un
costume à condition que ce soit pas trop
triste
en substance à un cheval vous avez lu
j'aurais aimé qu'elle replace un peu le
sujet dans sa vraie dimension c'est à
dire non affichage de de catégorie
sociaux professionnelles on affichage
laïcité peut-être parce que c'est ça au
fond qui qui
on a dépassé le temps et je note sur mon
débat premier lieu de passionnant donc
je vous remercie maintenant merci à tous
les trois d'y avoir participé